The first thing we want to do, is what's called "procedural abstraction."
This is a really powerful idea--
this is--one of the ways we avoid having to do things over and over again by hand,
is that we can write the code--
write it once, and use it many times--
changing the inputs to get different behaviors.
If you look at each segment of code here,
these lines were copied exactly the same way.
We did the same thing, over and over again--
the same five lines of code--
to find the start of a link in "page,"
to find the start and end quote
and then to extract the URL,
and then to print the URL.
The only thing that was different was the value of "page."
We kept updating the value of "page"--
we did that as we went through the code--
we updated the value of "page" with this assignment
and, before this one, we updated the value of "page"
with this assignment.
So, the idea behind procedural abstraction, is that
anything that we're doing over and over again
we want to abstract--
we want to make it a procedure--
and we want to make the things that change, inputs.
That means, instead of having to type in this code over and over again,
we want to make "page" an input--
"page" is the input; that's something that changes--
and we want to make the URL--
that's the result we want--
an output.
That's our goal, to turn this into a procedure,
where "page" is the input--
we can do the same code, over and over again,
and every time we do it,
we want to get this URL value as the output.